Let's turn our attention to how the operating
system (OS) deals with input/output devices.
There are actually two parts to the discussion.
First, we'll talk about how the OS interacts
with the devices themselves.
This will involve a combination of interrupt
handlers and kernel buffers.
Then we'll discuss how supervisor calls access
the kernel buffers in response to requests
from user-mode processes.
As we'll see, this can get a bit tricky when
the OS cannot complete the request at the
time the SVC was executed.
Here's the plan!
When the user types a key on the keyboard,
the keyboard triggers an interrupt request
to the CPU.
The interrupt suspends execution of the currently-running
process and executes the handler whose job
it is to deal with this particular I/O event.
In this case, the keyboard handler reads the
character from the keyboard and saves it in
a kernel buffer associated with the process
that has been chosen to receive incoming keystrokes.
In the language of OSes, we'd say that process
has the keyboard focus.
This transfer takes just a handful of instructions
and when the handler exits, we resume running
the interrupted process.
Assuming the interrupt request is serviced
promptly, the CPU can easily keep up with
the arrival of typed characters.
Humans are pretty slow compared to the rate
of executing instructions!
But the buffer in the kernel can hold only
so many characters before it fills up.
What happens then?
Well, there are a couple of choices.
Overwriting characters received earlier doesn't
make much sense: why keep later characters
if the earlier ones have been discarded.
Better that the CPU discard any characters
received after the buffer was full, but it
should give some indication that it's doing
so.
And, in fact, many systems beep at the user
to signal that the character they've just
typed is being ignored.
At some later time, a user-mode program executes
a ReadKey() supervisor call, requesting that
the OS return the next character in R0.
In the OS, the ReadKey SVC handler grabs the
next character from the buffer, places it
in the user's R0, and resumes execution at
the instruction following the SVC.
There are few tricky bits we need to figure
out.
The ReadKey() SVC is what we call a "blocking
I/O" request, i.e., the program assumes that
when the SVC returns, the next character is
in R0.
If there isn't (yet) a character to be returned,
execution should be "blocked", i.e., suspended,
until such time that a character is available.
Many OSes also provide for non-blocking I/O
requests, which always return immediately
with both a status flag and a result.
The program can check the status flag to see
if there was a character and do the right
thing if there wasn't, e.g., reissue the request
at a later time.
Note that the user-mode program didn't have
any direct interaction with the keyboard,
i.e., it's not constantly polling the device
to see if there's a keystroke to be processed.
Instead, we're using an "event-driven" approach,
where the device signals the OS, via an interrupt,
when it needs attention.
This is an elegant separation of responsibilities.
Imagine how cumbersome it would be if every
program had to check constantly to see if
there were pending I/O operations.
Our event-driven organization provides for
on-demand servicing of devices, but doesn't
devote CPU resources to the I/O subsystem
until there's actually work to be done.
The interrupt-driven OS interactions with
I/O devices are completely transparent to
user programs.
Here's sketch of what the OS keyboard handler
code might actually look like.
Depending on the hardware, the CPU might access
device status and data using special I/O instructions
in the ISA.
For example, in the simulated Beta used for
lab assignments, there's a RDCHAR() instruction
for reading keyboard characters and a CLICK()
instruction for reading the coordinates of
a mouse click.
Another common approach is to use "memory-mapped
I/O", where a portion of the kernel address
space is devoted to servicing I/O devices.
In this scheme, ordinary LD and ST store instructions
are used to access specific addresses, which
the CPU recognizes as accesses to the keyboard
or mouse device interfaces.
This is the scheme shown in the code here.
The C data structure represents the two I/O
locations devoted to the keyboard: one for
status and one for the actual keyboard data.
The keyboard interrupt handler reads the keystroke
data from the keyboard and places the character
into the next location in the circular character
buffer in the kernel.
In real life keyboard processing is usually
a bit more complicated.
What one actually reads from a keyboard is
a key number and a flag indicating whether
the event is a key press or a key release.
Knowing the keyboard layout, the OS translates
the key number into the appropriate ASCII
character,
dealing with complications like holding down
the shift key or control key to indicate a
capital character or a control character.
And certain combination of keystrokes, e.g.,
CTRL-ALT-DEL on a Windows system, are interpreted
as special user commands to start running
particular applications like the Task Manager.
Many OSes let the user specify whether they
want "raw" keyboard input (i.e., the key numbers
and status) or "digested" input (i.e., ASCII
characters).
Whew!
Who knew that processing keystrokes could
be so complicated!
Next, we'll figure out how to code the associated
supervisor call that lets user programs read
characters.